when i was lucky enough to
concretely solidify that this show
this show was happening of course you
get asked a lot
who would you like to have as a guest
who would be your first guest what's
your dream guest
um and every single time it was the same
name
david sedaris and
um he is my favorite writer
he's one of my favorite humans he's
brought more to my life
than most people honestly i'm this is
just
i'm freaking out i can't believe this
it's like you talk about something
and then it actually comes true he's a
best-selling author a humorous and
observationist
and just one of my personal heroes he is
a genius this is his new book the best
of me it is a collection
of 25 years worth of his work this is my
first time meeting him
i'm freaking out it's david sedaris but
i'm supposed to be i'm supposed to be
freaking out so i so appreciate you
being that way
because now i'm not i'm going to be
completely
my job's to calm you down that's what
i'm here for
your writing is also in some
at some points fictitious but then at
some point
so brutally true raw honest
vulnerable it feels very personal
do you have like conjured memories and
then go that's a story i need to write
about that
i mean sometimes i felt like for the
earlier books that i wrote
essay collections it was big things that
had happened in my life
right you know like my mother dying was
a big thing uh
but nothing really big happens to me
anymore so it's just more writing about
little things i mean sometimes your life
just feels like a story
but then how do you david sedaris a
fight
like where do you get those ornaments
as a metaphor to stick in there
that just are mind-blowingly funny
i don't know i mean the hard thing about
this pandemic is usually i'm on tour
so i go to like 100 cities a year and i
read out loud
and i'll read new stuff and then i go
back to my room and rewrite it and read
it and rewrite it
but since it's pandemic i've written a
bunch of stuff but i don't know if it's
any good
because i haven't been able to read it
out loud and i haven't had the
audience's reaction
to it so i don't it's an oddest
sensation to have all this material and
have
like i don't dare publish it because it
could
stink like the audience is such a good
editor
for me do you have
a meter inside that says
too far or don't care
and does it vacillate
the too far meter i know what that's
like to be on stage
and then just to think oh
i'm just going to try this
and but i think that's really important
to do
but you know if i try something new and
it doesn't
work out i i don't i'm not
then you let it i'd more like
congratulate myself like well that's how
you learn it didn't work
but that's why i feel fortunate
to be a writer right because a problem
it's or when somebody's mean to me right
like if someone's mean to
uh my older sister right then it just
kind of ruins her
her weak and it's just awful but if
somebody's mean to me
it's like they handed me money and i
think thank you so much
i'm going to go home and write about
that if you write
and if you write humor nothing that
horrible can happen to you
that you can't use as material when you
can write
the comedy that you do about the human
condition
that to me is the most productive
cathartic interesting challenge
that we can do as human beings to take
in this circus we're all living in
and do something positive with it that
affects someone else really nicely
like me the reader so thank you i like
how you said that you're like you're
really mad but it
turned out to be a positive thing your
tone and everything
was like at the end that's why you
deserve to be in prison
um is there one thing that you haven't
written
about yet that you would like to
somebody said
write about the thing that you are most
embarrassed about
and usually it's the things that you're
embarrassed about or you're ashamed of
that most people can relate to
because we're not that different right
so
i tried that this summer but i haven't
tried it out loud yet because i don't
know
and it's really bad but
i'm guessing that maybe a lot of people
can relate to it they'd be sick people
but but there are plenty of sick people
out there
and i think they'll be able to relate to
it
[Laughter]
is there one thing that you will never
write about
i don't write about sex especially like
if you're
in front of an audience and you're
talking about graphically about sex
people are going to undress you and then
put you in position
but like when you're 63 nobody wants to
imagine you naked
yeah i've lived so many again
part of my crazy existence of being so
wild is why i'm
it's the road i took and that's why i'm
here i
love people i care about people i feel
like i was put on this planet to help
maintain pleasant energy around that's
my life's mission
but i am so sick of the expectation
of perfection and i think it's going to
do us all in
see you got that tone again i am sick
to death i love people for who they
really are
not what they're supposed to be and it's
a finger pointing
i love you because you just lay it all
out there in this creative
personal real fictitious beautiful
package
that i eat like morsels and ingest them
and i just think
yes yes this is what human beings are
like and you know
what we should still love each other and
deal with it and talk about it and
accept or
gripe or fix or do something but
stop with the you're supposed to be this
way and you're not it's like
angry merriment
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and that is the way i want to go into
this holiday
with some angry
so have a good thanksgiving dance
you know best you can be
for who you really are and not who
you're supposed to be
and reach out to others because you're
never gonna be society's cookie cutter
mold
and you can't cook
[Laughter]
david sedaris the best of me
is available right now pick it up
turn the pages and enjoy some real life
put in the most perfect package i've
ever known
you